Hey youtubers it's Charlie, since there's
a lot of Guardians of The Galaxy stuff going
on I thought it would be fun to single out
one of the cooler characters and do a breakdown
of them in the comics and in the movie.
So this is going to be all about Ronan the
Accuser.
And there has been some news about the Hulk
maybe doing a team up movie with the Guardians
out in space in Phase 3, so I'll explain what's
going on with that too.
Hello to all the new people, if you're finding
me for the first time I do Marvel and DC videos
every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Guardians is the next big thing coming up
by I try to rotate between different Avengers
and all the spinoff movies.
So because the Hulk Phase 3 stuff is what
everyone is going crazy about right now I'll
do that first.
It's pretty straightforward.
A couple of news sites are reporting that
instead of a stand alone Hulk film in phase
3, Marvel will just use Mark Ruffalo with
another Team.
The only other big movie team right now is
the Guardians of The Galaxy.
So he'd go from the Avengers to the Space
Avengers.
Even though in the comics the actual Avengers
go into space all the time.
Everyone at Marvel loves Mark Ruffalo and
his version of the Hulk, he's just been saying
in interviews that they're not quite ready
for another mega solo movie.
But they do want to do a non-Avengers Hulk
Movie.
Which means team-up.
And I think that because the Hulk is a great
source for comedy, like when he punched Thor
at the end of Avengers.
He'd be perfect for a more comedically driven
Marvel film like Guardians of The Galaxy.
He's not going to be in any post credits for
this first Guardians movie or anything, this
would be the next Guardians movie in Phase
3.
There's no date for that right now, but the
way they're getting Hulk into space sounds
like a modified version of Planet Hulk.
These are all rumors, but based on the Hulk
Phase 3 Guardians Team Up, they sound pretty
plausible.
So just in case, careful for potential spoilers
for the end of Avengers 2.
You can totally just turn the volume down
for like 30 seconds.
Everybody Ready I'll wait just a sec...
Okay.
So supposedly at the end of Avengers the solution
to Ultron is that they can't kill him.
In order to solve the problem they pull a
Planet Hulk and shoot him into deep space
in a spaceship that's meant to double as a
prison.
Hulk is the one that fights him onto the ship
but in the process get's stuck on it as it
leaves for orbit.
Because it's pre-programmed and the Hulk doesn't
have the Homer Simpson dialing wand for pushing
buttons he ends up getting shot into deep
space too.
If you haven't read it, you should read the
Planet Hulk comic book, they turned it into
a cartoon movie too.
It's one of the best Hulk stories in the last
10 years.
Let me know what you think about the idea
of the Hulk teaming up with the Guardians
of The Galaxy?
We haven't even seen their first movie yet,
but I'm really optimistic that it's going
to be awesome.
I like the idea of the Hulk being more of
a journeyman character in the Marvel Universe.
So now that you're thinking about the Guardians
let's talk about Ronan The Accuser, he's being
played by Lee Pace, even if you can't tell
from all the Kree makeup and face mask.
He'll be the main villain of the movie.
I know we've got Thanos and The Collector,
two even bigger characters.
But supposedly the Collector is supposed to
be more of a neutral figure and Thanos is
supposedly only showing up in Holo Communications.
Like he'll be galactic skyping Ronan, Nebula
and Korath.
So who is Ronan?
He's a Kree leader of the Accuser Corps, they're
the space militia of the Kree Empire.
They're the Kree's version of the Nova Corps.
He considers the Xandarians, the race that
originated the Nova Corps, to be his mortal
enemies.
So when you see the Kree ships descending
on Xandar, that's Ronan's Accuser Corps attacking
the planet.
Ronan isn't necessarily a villainous character,
it's just that his goals of eliminating his
enemies, the Xandarians, causes him to forge
an alliance with Thanos.
The true villain of the story.
Because the Guardians and the protagonists
in this movie, Ronan by aligning himself with
evil, is a villain.
But that doesn't mean he'll stay a villain
in all the future Guardians movies.
There have been times in the comics where
he teams up with Peter Quill and the Nova
Corps and he even teamed-up with Thor and
the Avengers last year in Marvel's Infinity
storyline.
Ronan is a servant of his people, the Kree
Empire.
So he does anything he can to protect them.
Sometimes that means fighting with Marvel
Heroes, sometimes with Villains.
So when you see him in the movie, expect him
to come off as more of an anti-hero or a villain
of circumstance.
He's not evil.
But that doesn't mean his team mates Karen
Gillain and Dijimon Hinsou won't tear shit
up.
In the Kree Empire he's second only to the
Supreme Intelligence.
That character isn't supposed to be in the
movie, at least it hasn't been confirmed.
Most of the Kree we see are blue skinned,
but those are just the upper class kree.
So Ronan is like an aristocrat in his society.
Which makes him even more of a dick, I don't
expect the movie to go too deep into the inner
workings of the Kree Empire, but in the Nova
comics he's had a lot of political intrigue
thriller stories.
The trailers for the movie are really showing
off his hammer though.
So I think he'll spend equal amounts of time
speechifying and smashing stuff.
I've seen a lot of you guys speculate based
on the trailer footage that his hammer is
somehow connected to one of the infinity gems.
Because his hammer is glowing purple it would
have to be the Space Gem, because that's the
purple one.
It gives the user the ability to manipulate
Space as in travel.
So it will teleport you anywhere you can think
of.
His Hammer you see in the trailers is actually
called The Universal Weapon, it's the most
powerful hand held weapon the Kree have.
It's similar to Thor's hammer.
It can create force fields, fire energy blasts
and gives Ronan the ability to fly.
It also has some cosmic properties that allow
him to transmute matter.
So I'm expecting to see him warp some stuff
in the movie with it.
It has some cool safety mechanisms just like
Thor's Hammer too.
Thor's Hammer can only be used by someone
deemed worthy according to Odin's standards.
Captain America is one of the few people besides
Thor and Odin who have used it in the comics.
Ronan's Universal Weapon can only be used
by a Kree wearing cybernetic armor like you
see him wearing in the trailer.
If someone else tried to picked it up they'd
be shocked to death.
Another big difference between Ronan's Weapon
and Thor's Hammer is that there is only one
Mjolnir.
There are many versions of the Universal Weapon,
Ronan just has the most powerful one.
So his hammer does have properties that mimic
some of the the infinity gems powers, but
it's not powered by a gem.
I think the Orb Peter Quill is trying to steal
is the actual gem, probably the space gem.
And yes, I do think this movie will revolve
around an infinity gem.
Remember, as we progress through each Marvel
movie, we have to establish all six of the
gems so that when we get to Avengers 3 we
can do the infinity gauntlet.
It's not currently known whether or not Marvel
is going to change the way the infinity gems
work.
I've heard stories that they're calling the
Tesseract one of the gems, in the comics that's
not true.
The cube in the comics is a container for
an unknown power source that slowly gains
sentience.
It imposes it's will on people that wield
it.
The first Avengers movie teased the idea that
the Cube was showing Hawkeye and Loki things,
so let's assume for now that the cube is not
one of the gems.
Ronan is basically chasing Peter Quill through
the movie to get the Orb for Thanos.
That's the bargain he made, trade the Orb
to Thanos in exchange for eliminating the
Xandarians.
So in the trailers when we see Djimon Hinsou
going after Chris Pratt, he's playing Korath.
He's really working for Ronan.
I'm really hoping that the movie leaves the
Ronan character in a place that allows him
to team up with the Guardians in a future
movie.
They don't have to be best friends or anything.
Even Glenn Close and John C. Reilly of the
Nova Corps think they're a bunch of galactic
assholes.
But because we haven't seen the movie yet
it's almost too soon to speculate on what
the sequel movie might be about.
Definitely another Thanos-centric story but
we just started doing space-based movies.
So there's almost too many options.
Usually sequels go deeper into stories involving
the cool side characters.
Like Michael Rooker's Yondu.
He's more of a space pirate in this movie,
but I could totally see the Guardians introducing
the Nova character.
He's not in this movie, but expect to see
some easter eggs.
And if they do end up making the sequel movie
a Hulk Crossover, imagine him fighting Thanos.
They actually did that last year in the comics.
In reality, I don't think anyone will meet
Thanos in physical combat until Avengers 3.
Until then he's going to be like the Emperor
in Star Wars.
Just sitting above it all watching everyone
dance around.
So now it's your turn, let me know if you
think they'll ever do a Ronan Guardians team
up and do you believe the rumors about a Hulk
Guardians team up movie?
I totally think it could happen.
And if you're a big Lee Pace fan and you've
already re-watched Desolation of Smaug a billion
times, check out Halt and Catch Fire.
He's not wearing any makeup or prosthetics
in it, but it's a fun tv show.
I'm going to be doing more Guardians Bonus
videos in the next couple of weeks before
the movie comes out.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And let me know which character you want me
to talk about next.
I might do Karen Gillan next week.
She's playing Nebula
and looks amazing.
Right now click here to learn more story rumors
for Avengers 2 and click here for my breakdown
of the Guardians of the Galaxy Trailer.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!